[Music]
hello Marva lights I'm Mariah aka agent
M I've got bill Roseman hey there Eric
Mona celli and we just gave you the
trailer for Marvel's Avengers let's take
a look cap what's going on over there
start to Chimera what's your status
no stay on task
[Music]
you guys just saw the trailer for
Marvel's Avengers and ho boy
very exciting boys yes and so we're here
to tell y'all about six things we just
learned about Marvel's Avengers you guys
ready we're ready okay first things
first yes we have a release date we do
you amazing do it's May 15 20 20 and a
lot of platforms a lot of platforms so
we'll be on ps4 xbox pc
and stadium like that very excited okay
so number two we know who the Avengers
team is we do indeed can you give us
that roster well what would the Avengers
be without a leader like Captain America
who is played by Jeff Cheyne right-hand
man flying through the sky the armored
Avenger iron man by Nolan North how
about the Asgardian god of thunder Thor
that would be travis willingham how
about the Deadpool ultimate spy Black
Widow
Laura Bailey and you know sometimes you
need a doctor on your team that may
unleash your rage beast I'm talking
about dr. Bruce Banner and the whole
Troy Baker you guys and you didn't even
rehearse this you guys are all wonderful
so we got to talk about the game story
we learned a lot about what the story is
for Marvel's Avengers so as you saw
tonight the game story begins on a day
it's a celebration of Avengers however
during a day tragedy strikes there is
some devastation things go south is it a
setup
who knows
they're blamed for the tragedy they're
blamed for the devastation but five
years later a new evil arises and our
only hope for the world is for Earth's
Mightiest Heroes to reassemble once
again I like it all right that's all we
can talk about the story but story's
only part of the of the whole thing we
also learn about the gameplay the
gameplay yes so we'll have a
single-player campaign which is covered
off most of what we heard in the story
but also we'll be continuing that
narrative for years and years to come in
a multiplayer four player co-op game wow
you just hit two of the most important
points because single-player and co-op
and that we're gonna be playing for a
long time which means there will be new
additional heroes and regions that will
cost you nothing zero okay finally yes
we learned that the game is gonna be
super customizable yes tell me about
that so we'll have our heroes that you
can get for em are free and those heroes
will have outfits some original some of
your fan favorite outfits some plastic
elephants yep just everything you could
try on check them out and we'll have all
these different heroes that will be
unlocking overtime and some all new
designs that that crystal Marvel games
collaborated on made just for this game
yeah it's pretty exciting yes very
exciting lots more for us to talk about
share and learn for Marvel's Avengers
gentlemen thank you very much reassemble
let's go have some fun
[Music]